[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
welcome to this new series two minute
miracles where we try and give
evidences for the veracity of islam
within two minutes this ramadan
and many people know that we already do
something called sapient thoughts which
are
longer expositions which can be found in
the sapiens institute
youtube channel today insha allah is
very simple
that you may have heard this verse
already pharaoh said in the quran
i am your lord most high now what is
miraculous about this or what is
remarkable about this or what is
interesting about this
is that if especially if we take that
ramp sister ii he is
the pharaoh of the old testament and the
quran
that he indeed claimed to be god now
this is not mentioned in the bible and
it's mentioned in the quran
this already dispels two claims that the
quran copied from the bible
but also the fact the question is how
could it be the case
that something so grandiose and
something so central
to the historical narrative as the
leader of egypt claiming divinity
is not mentioned in the old testament
and is mentioned the quran
especially considering the hieroglyphics
were only unlocked
in 1799 when the rosetta stone
unlocked the hieroglyphics so this is a
question
already with these questions we can see
that the misnomers that the quran was
copied from the old testament
and indeed even now the additional
questions that we may have
of where this information would have
come from would be at the four
of our inquiries and this is a good
evidence for the veracity of islam
because it shows things that quite
frankly on on probabilistic reasoning
are unlikely to have come from seventh
century authorship
was allah